Rhianna turns heads at the 2017 Met Gala  [Music]  the 29 year old singer stepped out for  the Costume Institute benefit at the  Metropolitan Museum of Art in NYC on  Monday in this bold number and she did  not disappoint  Rihanna looked stunning and on theme in  this large and floral print comme des  Garcons ensemble by the Gala's featured  designer of the night Rae Kawakubo she  accessorized the look perfectly rocking  ruby and diamond jewels along with  lace-up thigh high heels her hair  slicked back in a sleek bun and bangs  even rear ease makeup was to die for  both her eye shadow and face highlight  complementing her bright cranberry lips  shine bright like a diamond who are your  favorite 2017 Met Gala look let us know  over on Twitter at ET now  [Music]  you